es ist wirklich ein absolut irres ding
der deutsche mathematiker peter scholze
gehört zu den besten der welt er wurde
jetzt mit der fields medaille
ausgezeichnet es ist die höchste
auszeichnung die mathematiker halten
können wird nur alle vier jahre vergeben
und gilt demnach als nobelpreis für
mathematik wofür hat er sie bekommen
jetzt den klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen peter scholze gilt
als mozart unter den mathematikern erst
wirklich in der lage neue theorien oder
beweise aus dem ärmel zu schütteln
er macht etwas was einfach niemand so
außer ihm kann bei mozart ist bekannt
dass er so gearbeitet hat der komponist
komponierte an einem tag drei
klavierkonzerte im kopf und brauchte
dann wochen um sie auf notenpapier
festzuhalten und genauso ist es bei
peter scholze inspiriert vom vortrag
eines kollegen aber ein beweis komplett
im kopf entwickelt um ihn dann in sechs
monaten aufzuschreiben und er ab so
funktioniert so ein mathe professor
michael rapoport und hier geht es nicht
um punkt oder strich rechnung scholze
beschäftigt sich mit wirklich hoch
komplexen problemen wie zum beispiel den
perfekten räumen
die entwickelte er selbst in seiner
doktorarbeit damit können probleme aus
der zahlentheorie mit diesem
geometrischen ansatz bewiesen werden ein
neues werkzeug für mathematiker und
mathematikerinnen ein bisschen so als
würde man sich die kurve einer formel
ansehen und sie dadurch viel besser
verstehen
peter scholze hatte als kind schon die
besten startbedingungen mathematik
lernte er an einer in der ddr
gegründeten spezialschule die
hochbegabten beste bedingungen bietet
der heinrich hertz schule hier in berlin
friedrichshain
zitat ich war im matheunterricht immer
recht gut ja das sagt scholze etwas
bescheiden über seine zeit dort er ist
auf der ewigen bestenliste der
internationalen mathematik olympiade auf
rang elf dreimal gewann er gold und
einmal silber
zitat mir war von anfang an klar dass er
ein außergewöhnliches talent ist so sein
mathe professor michael rapoport bei dem
er an der universität bonn seinen
master gemacht hat und diese maßarbeit
hat stolze in nur fünf monaten
geschrieben zitat sie war so
außerordentlich dass ich sie gleich an
kollegen geschickt habe allerdings kann
otto normalverbraucher mit den
forschungen scholz es rein gar nichts
anfangen er arbeitet in den bereichen
der reinen mathematik nichts davon ist
praxisbezogen und wenn mal eine seiner
methoden in der praxis anwendung finden
würde dann wäre das reiner zufall
wenn es dazu kommen sollte dann erwarb
das natürlich hier bei klicks und wenn
er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässiger abo boxee auf youtube
und er verpasst kann wie du denn über
whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
und auch andere messenger von jedem
upload und zwar noch vor allen an und
zwar täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal krieg zum social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
dort klicken deutsches mathe genie
beweis alte formel bis dann bleibt dran